on va passer au premier débat du jour on
va revenir sur cette
décision de France Télévision qui fait
beaucoup réagir tous les films de Gérard
de pardieu ne sont plus diffusé sur la
chaîne sur les chaînes du service public
pour le moment c'est Manuel aldui
directeur du cinéma et du développement
international de France Télévision qui
l'a annoncé lui-même ceux qui s'en
foutent peuvent le direin voilà ceux qui
vous dites oui absolument il faut mettre
en pause j'aime bien le mot pause il y a
des accusations et surtout complément
d'enquête quoi qu'on en pense c'était
chez eux donc je pense qu'il a une de
groupe après ce qu'on a entendu dans la
bouche de Gérard pardie cette semaine
c'est difficile pour moi de faire comme
si de rien nétait de continuer à
diffuser les films sur france télé ils
on quand mêmeindignation attends ils ont
l'indignation à géométrie variable ils
ont quand même diffusé le jacuse de
Roman
Polanski et là ça y est c'est un
tribunal maintenant France
Télévision qu'on soit choqué du
reportage que c'était dégueulasse
c'était ignoble on peut on va pas
discuter de ça simplement là je te dis
ils ont quand même diffusé du PO ski al
dans ces cas-là c'est un tribunal France
Télévision c'est pas bien monsieur aldui
il a tort ça ça veut dire qu'on supprime
tout les films qui qui sont entre
guillemets problématiques donc ça veut
dire que par exemple tous les films qui
ont été produits parenstein il y en a au
moins 300 on les supprime tous qu'est-ce
qu'on fait à ce momentlà parce il
faudrait qu'on reprenne les uns après
les autres tous les films et on ne
pourrait plus voir je sais pas les films
de Tarantino les films de ce artist et
cetera et cetera et le pianiste il le
diffuse plus alors on pourrait plus
regardez le pianiste on pourrait plus et
là par exemple je ne sais pas mais euh
il est lui-même euh de Part Dieu on
l'aime ou on aime pas le téléspectateur
décide ou ou décide de ne pas regarder
ou décide de regarder c'est pas il y a
pas d'autodafé c'estàd on va pas brûler
des livres on va pas brûler des œuvres
euh le dernier métro par exemple qui est
un film absolument sublime on va plus
regarder le dernier métro parce qu'il
est dedans et tout et toute l'équipe du
film et Catherine de neuve et les
réisateurs et les techniciens et cetera
ch on va plus voir la ch on va voir
voilà la chèv et en revanche on disent
ils ont le droit des distributeurs ou
des producteurs disent je ne veux plus à
l'avenir tourner avec de Part Dieu ça
c'est autre chose mais les œuvres qui
préexistent non chacun sera libre de les
regarder ou pas et ça c'est la
conscience du téléspectateur vous avez
un avis finalement bah j'ai un petit
avis parce que est-ce qu'on peut être un
peu plus mesuré et se dire que là et ben
apparemment c'est un truc temporaire
donc ils ont pas dit que qu'ils allaient
le supprimer à vie juste peut-être en se
disant on sait jamais s'il y a des
victimes peut-être par respect pour les
VI
et se dire imaginons il s'est passé
quelque chose et on rediffusera après
enfin je veux dire on peut pas non plus
être directement en se disant ah mais
non je suis contre sinon faut supprimer
tout le monde moi je suis d'accord avec
toi à ce moment-là quand on pense comme
ça mais là on a quand même vu des
excusez-moi mais moi je suis TR dessus
ce weekend je suis encore choquée des
vidéos que j'ai vu même si elle devait
pas sortir il faut se le dire je suis
très choqué donc oui je peux comprendre
qu'à un moment donné on se dise ben on
va suspendre au cas où et on va
éclaircir l'histoire allez oui ouais ben
justement comme le dit Kell moi je me
mets à la place des victimes en fait euh
et contrairement à un réalisateur des
victimes supposé en tout cas présumé bon
il y a quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
témoignages euh quand tu dis que quand
tu fais des comparaisons avec par
exemple des réalisateurs le réalisateur
tu vois pas son visage sur la sur ton
écran de télé euh moi je me mets à la
place des victimes qui vont zapper qui
vont se retrouver devant le visage de
leur potentiel agresseur et ou même les
familles de de ces victimes donc je fais
vraiment quand même une différence entre
un réalisateur par exemple euh et un
acteur qui qui incarne un personnage
souvent des personnages clés dans les
dans les films donc moi je me dis
finalement ne pas voir son visage pour
l'instant ça me semble être totalement
légitime est-ce mounirir Mounir comment
tu m'appelis mir c'est gentil écoute moi
j'avais dit oui mais je crois que
finalement j'en dire non bravo bah vas-y
ouais je vais dire non pourquoi parce
que j'ai dit du 7è s de conviction ouais
c'est vrai non non mais c'est vrai non
mais j'ai le droit j'ai le droit pourqui
quand on quand on un peu
court non non et puis par tu me parles
de conviction moi je parlais de
conviction de père c'est vrai quand
quand j'ai vu ce ce ce ce reportage ooui
il parle de la petite fille en tant que
père effectivement c'est révoltant et si
le père était là il l'urait mis une tête
évid exactement mais je je je pense que
sa carrière elle doit pas être mélangée
à à ce qui s'est passé et ces films sont
exceptionnels moi je continue à les
regarder voilà oui moi je dis que c'est
de l'hypocrisie parce qu'il dit on
suspend mais je rejoins Valérie à ce
moment-là tu enlèves tu enlèves toutes
les personnes sur le service public qui
ont été accusé de quelque chose de pas
bien parce qu'il y a plein de gens qui
viennent sur service public
on été accusé par la justice de choses
de pas bien ou qui sont soupçonné
soupçonné de choses de pas bien moi je
veux pas que tu touches à la chè je veux
pas que tu touches au compère je veux
pas que tu touches au fugitif si un
Bergerac tu veux pas
regarder tu ch de chaî tu veux pas
regarder tu changes de chaîne c'est le
public qui va décider si tu mets la
chèvre et que tu fais 500000
téléspectateurs que c'est un bid ils
vont l'enlever de même le public veut
pas on va voir la vi des téléspectateurs
dans moi je suis très pragmatique avec
mon mon oui je dis quand on est
directeur des programmes qu'on assume ce
qu'on a diffusé sur FR on peut pas aussi
profiter du succès des films de Jard de
pardu et diffusé derrière pas mal
cohérent non c'est pas mal ce qu'elle
ditut être
cohérentement pas mal c'est tu vois j'ai
bien fait de la
transférer fa la transfér je te jure V
500 contre tu peux tu peux ah non voilà
% non moi je trouve que tout a été dit
effectivement moi aujourd'hui par
exemple s'il y a un film de de par Dieu
qui se fait je n'y vais pas et je suis
choquée qu'on le finance cont
mais tout ce qu'il a fait
parceffectivement il y a des équipes des
techniciens il a des auteurs et tout ça
et tout le monde vit aussi de de son
travail ça je trouve que c'est choquant
et à ce moment-là oui à ce moment-là
fermons immédiatement les misé Picasso
parce que Picasso a été
voilàé un personnage absolument immonde
arrêtons d'écouter les musiques de
Claude François et voilà et je pense
qu'on va pas canceller je pense qu'il
faut expliquer et je me souviens quand
même toujours du cas de Benjamin Mendy
qui a été accusé de 7 viol et qui a été
au final blanchi donc attention aux
justice méditi aussi
mouci
de exactement je l'embrasse d'ailleurs
Benjamin je l'embrasse fort perdu ouais
ouais ouais me il va tout récupérer on
va se retrouver dans un instant les chir
on revient dans 2 minutes à tout de
suiteir on va revenir sur les enfants de
la télé qui marche moins bien depuis le
départ de Laurent rier il faut l'avouer
voilà donc pourquoi ça marche moins bien
vous allez nous le
dire déjà donc j'ai j'ai fait un petit
débrief avec les équipes j'ai regardé le
replay j'ai pas regardé j'ai pas ça à
[__] non plus déjà dans l'émission ce
qu'on attend c'est des casseroles là ça
a commencé à
18h27 avec un bonjour de Laurent
bocolini et la première casserole est
arrivé 30 minutes plus tard et en plus
elle était pas ouf
regardez bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue
dans Les enfants de la télé c'est un VO
plaisir de vous retrouver chaque
dimanche
soir qui parmi vous est adepte de
naturisme qui est assez à l'aise avec
son corps pour se baigner nu c'est vous
Florence spnel ah mince ah
mince imbile r mes fruses disnous ce que
tu sais sur Jean-Pierre sinon on te
laisse comme ça et puis raccrap tes frs
il y a tes vieux j'ai pas so
[Musique]
vous 19 alors Florence alors ça marche
moins bien qu'avec Laurent Ruy pourquoi
Gill pour moi il y a un énorme manque de
rythme c'estàd que vous regardez c'est
hyper lent très long les deux premières
interviews sont interminables c'est St
déjà des joilles en face absolument mais
oui mais il y a pas que ça cyil c'est
globalement et et en plus je trouve que
il y a pas d'interactivité entre les
chroniqueurs ça passe que par elle
verticalement et les relances sont trop
molles on s'ennuie oui bonsoir Kelly oui
non mais après c'est toujours difficile
de reprendre une émission qui cartonnait
avec avec un monstre après c'est
peut-être le temps de de s'adapter elle
Ta fait un petit cadeau elle a dit avec
un monstre une content il est content
non mais moi je trouve que les résultats
sont pas si catastrophiques quand
même
mais j'ai même pas fini mais honnêtement
ça ça aurait pu être pire franchement ça
c'est quand même c'est pas si
dégueulasse surtout que je trouve que c
à8 est vachement plus puissant que les
autres années les interviews de Audrey
alle allez dis-moi la vérité non je te
jure tu regardes plus quand c'était avec
Laurent quand c'est avec moi j'ai je
regarde pas quand c'est avec tuais quand
oui oui je regardais je trouve qu'il est
plus fait si moi mon point de vue à moi
c'est qu'il est plus fait pour pour
faire ce genre d'émission elle est elle
est elle est un peu austère je trouve ah
oui mais h je mendais que ça soit enc
plus castropique et je trouve que c'est
pas castropique voilà c'est vra je c'est
vraiment un enfant de la télé en fait
qui la télévision et la fabrication des
médias il connait la télé par cœur et
Laurence Bini moi je la trouve très bien
mais pour les jeux et je trouve que
c'est pas une fille de la télé c'est pas
une femme de la télé c'est pas pareil m
il av pas ils avent pas beaucoup de
choix franchement qui vous auriez
imaginé qui ça vou le faire sopie
d'avant moi je trouve que j'aime bien
Sophie d'avant mais elle elle est pareil
pas pas elle respire
dans les Mach de France 2 excuse-moi
elle était très vivante et dans le
téltelle est super bien
auss été pas mal sont les mêmes
producteurs ou pas ou oui c'est
exactement les mê prodeurs oui non parce
quand vous dites il y a une première
casserole qui arrive au bout de 30
minutes c'est les même production c'est
les même système c'est les mêmes
producteurs ou mais là trouv qu'elle
était faible c'est les mêm producteurs
c'est les mêmes producteurs mavais c'est
mauvais
ENF j'ai pas regardé mais moi je pense
que ça peut encore monter elle est loin
d'
c'est quand même une professionnelle de
la télé donc faut être un peu mesuré
làdessus je TR mais c'est normal je je
dis ce que je pense j'ai pas de
stratégie ni quoi que ce soit j'ai pas
d'intérêt tu as raison il c'est bien que
tu fasses ça j'aurais fait pareil
j'aurais fait pareil ma meuf elle aura
animé Les enfants de la télé avant et il
y a une autre meuf ils ont mis une autre
meuf j'aurais dit pareil jeis direis
découpisou je vais vous dire il regrette
pas du tout de toute façon peu importe
que ça fonctionne ou que ça fonctionne
pas il en a rien à [__] il a aucun
regr
hmee Mme pas les résultats tu vraiment
il est pas son genre la comparaison il
souhaite pas du mal à la personne qui
succède c'est pas son genre donc il m'en
parle même pas il a raison ouais voilà
il a raison merci Alle
discuter